[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  it's Halloween happy Halloween everyone  the queen of Halloween strikes again yes  that's Heidi Klum at her annual bash in  New York City paying tribute to Michael  Jackson Michael Jackson's Thriller video  is so iconic and it is so fabulous that  we had to redo that for Halloween  obviously I'm not as good as Michael no  one ever really is good as like a little  really tried my hardest  why is it that you love so much about  this party and about how you know it's  scary people are dressing out these are  unrecognizable and so that's the whole  fun of it feasel dressing out what's the  most uncomfortable part of this today  the teeth the teeth today is easy on my  seat is super easy and Michael's loafers  was so nice scrunchie shocks but the  tease is a little hard it's a little  hard and how did they put this on it's  all prosthetics it's all Forester digs  can I see under here oh yeah you're so  warm now I know Claudine scrunchy  [Music]